let's dive right in it's do or die
in the suburbs that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now it's a moment of truth for all you
moderates living in the suburbs
now many of you i know not all but many
of you voted against
donald trump by voting for biden and at
the time i think you felt good about it
virtuous even
especially you suburban women you're the
biggest voting cohort making up what 24
of the voters in 2020 and you went 59
for biden and only 40 for trump
well you felt good about yourselves at
the time
but what about now well the events of
the last year and especially the past
six months
demonstrate that you've got a lot a lot
more trouble than you bargained for
the fact is there are no more moderates
left in the democrat party to reign in
the radicals
and as i warn now i think it was exactly
almost
a year ago biden's too weak to stand up
to the hard left
my message to suburban women and older
voters
biden is not going to deliver the calm
that you think he might
the democrats have become the party of
chaos
lawlessness and disorder and when they
can't get their way through voting
they'll encourage rioting and looting
and if you resist or you don't publicly
profess your white guilt
they'll destroy you they hate our
history
our traditions and our way of life
well not to mention that biden's lackeys
want to wipe the suburbs off the map
now like everything else they see the
suburbs as themselves inherently racist
kind of a sign of decadent white
privilege built on the backs of minority
suffering
now as we've warned you the
administration will cajole localities
into eliminating so-called exclusionary
zoning laws that
make the suburbs possible goodbye picket
fence houses
hello high-rises and multi-use living
and of course the and crime that can
come along with it
now speaking of which biden's answer to
the terrifying spiral of crime that's
sweeping across the country
should itself be a wake-up call to all
you suburbanites who voted for him
his stupid gun control speech today just
confirms what we noted last night
that democrats defiantly refuse to do
what we
all know works to reduce crime and
they're doing that in favor of empty
symbolic gestures
that satisfy their rabid anti-second
amendment base
now under the leadership of president
bill clinton and with the help
of then senator joe biden and
republicans
remember they all tackled rising crime
in the 1990s did a good job of it
but now that the hard left is in charge
they're simply
never going to crack down on crime they
just mouth platitudes about
community engagement and then they
shovel taxpayer money out the door to
their cronies
this is not defunding our communities
it's
investing in them for crime prevention
and for community building and social
services
fostering trust with and earning
legitimacy in our communities
we know summer job training summer jobs
training and recreation
for young people work that help make
sure young people pick up
a paycheck instead of a pistol there are
a lot of things that we need to do on
the law enforcement side
including by the way addressing the rise
in domestic violent extremism
can always count on mazie for real
wisdom
now meanwhile the bodies continue to
pile up as crime
skyrockets taking not just black lives
but blue lives as well on monday
19-year colorado police force veteran
gordon beasley
was ambushed in broad daylight shot and
killed
today we learn more about the suspect's
motives
i can tell you that gordon was targeted
because he was wearing a nevada police
uniform
and a badge officer beasley was ambushed
by a person who expressed hatred of
police officers
now i wonder where that hatred was fed
from
monday was also one of chicago's
bloodiest days yet during the current
crime wave seven killed eleven wounded
yesterday one more was killed with five
wounded by gunfire including a
fifteen-year-old boy
shot in a drive-by but of all the
depressing headlines about inner city
america in the past few days
i found one particularly disturbing
57 dead in 50 days
as violence continues to ravage
baltimore city
today these two men christian saint rose
and jamal kingsborough were arrested for
the shocking
midday execution of 34 year old tony
hegspeth
yet no protests no marches no celebrity
demands for justice
for these victims and if you refuse to
submit
to what their thought process is about
why crime is exploding
what are they going to do they're going
to try to run you over
just like they did to those parents in
loudoun county virginia last night
[Applause]
oh
i know another place where they take a
similar approach to dissenting views
i think when you really think about it
china
actually has to love critical race
theory in fact
they humiliated biden's secretary of
state blinken in alaska last month
when china ended up parroting back to
him
the democrats go-to lines about
america's problem with systemic racism
so they were all probably elated over
there in beijing to hear
that biden's chairman of the joint
chiefs defended it
on capitol hill today first of all
on the issue of critical race theory etc
i do think it's important
actually uh for those of us in uniform
to be open-minded and be widely read i
want to understand white rage
and i'm white and i want to understand
it it's important that we understand
that
because our soldiers sailors airmen
marines and guardians they come from the
american people
it matters to our military in the
discipline and cohesion of this military
let's pull the active duty service men
and women about that sir
now somehow i don't think general milley
would ever speak
in this dismissive tone that he took
today
to his chinese counterparts not the way
he spoke to congressman waltz who
questioned him
i have a question for the general why
would
anyone risk his or her life for a
country
that's systemically racist one that
brutalizes minorities
why would any country respect us or
follow our lead if that's who we are
those are some of the questions he
should probably think about before he
touts the value
of teaching far left marxist racist
ideology to our troops
the fact is millie has made his choice
and he's chosen to indulge the radical
whims of democrats
he'll do everything they tell him as
long as they keep the military
industrial complex flush with cash
but is any of this what mothers and
fathers in the suburbs
thought they were getting when they
voted for sweet old joe
biden think about all of this
if you worked hard trying to raise a
family
if you paid your taxes you're a good
citizen
you have every right to expect that
where you live
will be safe and clean that your schools
will be functional they'll teach your
kids an informed patriotism
and prepare your children for the
challenging world ahead
i mean this should be the case no matter
where you live in a country
like the united states of america
whether in the
city or the or the country rural america
you know think about it in urban america
the middle class right now
it flees as soon as it can because
liberal leadership
has driven it all into the gutter in the
cities
but the hard left they're fine with
urban america living this way
but i don't think the rest of the
country wants to live that way
most republican-run states are
blueprints for better more prosperous
and safer living today but try to
imagine what our country is going to
look like
if the far left is allowed to get away
with teaching an entire generation or
two or three to despise our country and
its founding
to view the traditions we grew up loving
from singing the star-spangled banner at
a baseball game to flying our flag
consider those things like racist dog
whistles
plus let's remember many of you
suburbanites either run successful
businesses
or you work at one you may feel
insulated
i know from the madness around you
but if you think that you're sorely
mistaken no one is safe
in their land of thought control just in
the past month
everyone from a liberal playwright
lin-manuel miranda to singer billy
eilish
has felt the need to apologize for their
supposed unwoke-ism
and things went to a new level of the
absurd
when 89-year-old legend rita moreno
had to apologize for dismissing the
colorism attacks against mr miranda
the point is if those beloved
celebrities
aren't safe from these vicious takedown
mobs
why would your average suburban mother
without any power or celebrity status
things should be safe
they think putting up blm approved yard
signs or
trendy flags are going to protect them
they're not going to protect them
they think giving money to democrats or
black lives matter affiliated groups is
going to save them
it won't save them if the canceled
culture doesn't get you
the racial division squads and the
schools will get your kids
and then they're going to turn your kids
against you and then crime is going to
start seeping into your neighborhoods
just in time
for you to see the cost of everything go
up
and of course that means your paycheck
won't go as far
does that sound like building back
better to you
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else